where are we today a big focus on the
south of Ukraine isn't it yes uh this is
exactly two weeks since the beginning of
the Ukrainian offensive and it's all
shaping operations at the moment they're
still probing in three or four different
places but um today reports that Henry
chesk of this big ammunition dump being
blown up which is entirely plausible
because the ukrainians are looking for
all of the rare areas stocks that they
can get that the Russians may have of
course the Russians are doing the same
to the Ukrainian so that's uh entirely
likely more interesting in a way or just
as interesting is that Nova kakovka
there are a lot of reports still
unconfirmed but a lot of these reports
that the ukrainians may have crossed the
river presumably Upstream of the dam
that was blown on the 6th of June and if
they've crossed the river in any force
that is very interesting because there's
a big battle developing between oriciev
and top Mac the ukrainians are are south
of our kids now and they're trying to
widen the front now in the scheme of
things these are quite small operations
but nevertheless they're trying to widen
the front and I think they're trying to
stretch the Russians if they've crossed
the river then I think that part of the
other the idea behind that is because
the Russians withdrew quite a lot of
troops from this area after they blew
the dam the ukrainians may be trying to
persuade them to have to put troops back
there to to cover that and take troops
away from this area where they're now
fighting if the Russians don't choose to
do that and just risk it then they may
be risking letting the ukrainians build
up a force a significant force and open
up a new area whether that will turn out
to be the case or not I'm fairly
convinced that the ukrainians are now
beginning to Fan out a little bit and
they're trying to to pull the the
Russians away from certain
concentrations to see where the gaps
open up I see one thing I find very
interesting NATO's got this new center
hasn't it which isn't too far from where
we are designed to protect undersea
pipelines cables yep it's it's going to
be based at Northwood which is the
maritime command center it's the British
Maritime Command Center but it also
works for NATO it's the most important
Command Center this side of the Atlantic
within NATO and so this new center is to
deal with this sort of thing this is the
the Nordstrom one and Nordstrom 2
pipelines that were blown up on the 26th
of September last year NATO has been
worrying about this for about a decade
now the vulnerability of undersea
pipelines and particularly internet
cables now obviously pipelines gas and
and oil pipelines they're pretty big
things you've got to blow them up to
interrupt them undersea cables are much
easier to to interrupt and NATO is now
beginning to give a lot of thought to
building more ships and keeping an eye
on what the Russians are doing because
the Russians have been spying on all
these cables they've been sending spy
ships to hang around in some key areas
and we've been tracking them doing that
or our countries have been tracking them
doing it and so NATO has now set up this
Command Center in Britain to try to
coordinate what it's going to do we
mentioned yesterday didn't we these
nuclear warheads being set in at Belarus
clearly lukashenka can't do anything
with them they're at the under control
of the Russians any movement on that
today yeah well it's not a bit of
rhetoric I mean this is Putin when he
was meeting a ramaphosa those are when
the African group of African nations
visited him yesterday and he took the
opportunity there again to make the
point that uh nuclear weapons were going
into Belarus and have been talking about
this since March this year so it's no
surprise and it makes no operational
difference these weapons are under
Russian control they just happen to be
based in Belarus but Joe Biden has made
it very clear this is reckless this is
reckless talk and in saying that he's
only he's only echoing what Xi Jinping
of China has said and what a lot of
African leaders have said is that the
person who's doing all the Reckless talk
is Putin and people around him they're
the only ones talking about nuclear
escalation and nuclear dangers of this
crisis this crisis is not nuclear in any
respect but they keep raising the
Specter of nuclear weapons in order to
frighten everybody into feeling that the
crisis is out of control in some way all
right Michael for now many thanks indeed